hey babe what um nothing
how was on just asking how are you you
haven't asked me done in five Eva's I
remember because that was around the
time I started taking father than this
seriously yeah that's so not cool
that makes me wonder do you think maybe
we just like stop trying a little bit
what do you mean well you're wearing
Crocs which sucks so are you
is there flats oh I got some bad news
for you [ __ ] mm I feel like maybe we
just stopped trying maybe we need to
connect a little b.i stage houses for my
job I make all things look new and shiny
maybe that's what we need in a
relationship sounds expensive
yeah yeah maybe a little bit but do you
remember how we used to dress up how we
used to go out on sexy date so it's
probably not surprising that females
have a more active system for emotional
memory which means we recall feelings
not just facts something that's harder
for a man to do this is why it seems
like women can access visceral memories
with search engine like speed after
years of research we discovered the male
and female brain is wired very
differently to him I'm basically a
blow-up doll oh my god that is what you
look like
thank you well you know that grooming
releases endorphins in the female brain
let's not forget mrs. Preston I gave you
the Brazilian straightening I like my
hair it looked like those dudes from the
Dukes of Hazzard
I'm a it was my American accent you mean
you don't know the Dukes of Hazzard the
area responsible for defending your turf
is larger in the male brain I'm a
physical marvel Oh try me throw
something I mean anything okay so I
wasn't ready for that women are also
more likely to recognize flaws the hell
you're wearing I threw that thing out
like three years ago I take out the
trash so now these gender roles they've
been in us for 20,000 years you like
this look how's it feel to be dating
magician relationships take work want me
to work two jobs why don't we take the
drug morally it's not the one to make
you eat people's faces
[Music]
she returned some music on
[Music]
three let go one knowing your brain
makes life so much easier even though
people can be complicated nobody can
deny our ability to get back up yeah
yeah yeah you just said yet nine times
yeah can I tell you something yeah sure
I think you're a physical marvel I see
and she thought jelly jellies not really
something you catch jellies some great
eat yeah yeah you ready those were two
peppers in a bag he's like kitchen gnome
chefs
[Music]
you